[Musique]
et vous le retrouverez également aux
manettes de ses émissions spéciales
ryder cup michael et demi d'euros
bonsoir bonsoir grégory c'est dans vos
habitudes désormais avant votre 7,8
sport vous venez nous présenter les
principaux résultats du week-end dans le
département et les franciliens et
mickaël ont mis leurs chaussures de
running ce week end
oui de la course à pied n'est pas
n'importe quelle course grégory ont fêté
ce week-end la 41e édition du paris
versailles course mythique de 16 km qui
relie la tour eiffel au château
versailles en passant par la redoutable
côte des gardes à meudon vous la
connaissez bien grégory cette année 25
mille coureurs ont pris le départ de
l'épreuve le vainqueur et lui burundais
abraham niyonkuru s'est détaché dans le
sprint final pour s'imposer en cinquante
et une minutes et 31 secondes on écoute
le vainqueur ça me fait rêver a préféré
nier tout à cause des trois fines et aux
idées viennent chez les féminines c'est
l'éthiopienne hochart acquerra qui
l'emportent
à 22 ans la sportive franchi la ligne
d'arrivée en 1h01 et 35 secondes
elle devance la française laurie
lindekens de deux minutes tout ce beau
monde devrait se retrouver l'année
prochaine pour une 42e édition du paris
versailles
on range les baskets de running michael
on sort les ballons ovales vous parler
rugby à présent exactement le ballon
ovale commencé alors manqué et ça s'est
vu dans le championnat de division
honneur versailles faisait sa rentrée
sur le terrain de montesson après une
pause estivale et les versaillais ont
remporté leur premier match dans la
douleur en s'imposant 21 à 18
les victoires qui permet de lancer la
saison du rcv qui vise cette année une
montée en fédérale 3 avec un gros
recrutement effectué à l'intersaison
prochain match dimanche prochain à
domicile au stade de porchefontaine
contre le roc j fois toujours dans le
championnat de division honneur le
script bien repris son championnat par
un festival offensif avec à la clé une
victoire 26 à 5 sur le terrain de melun
combs senart 77 au classement cette
victoire lors de cette première journée
permet aux saint quentinois de prendre
la place de leader prochain match
dimanche prochain à 15 heures sur le
terrain de vaucresson un bon dimanche
pour les rugbymans yvelinois handball
est ce que les féminines ii
fini le bretonneux ont aussi connu la
victoire et oui grégory à montils retenu
c'est a largement imposés ce week-end
pour leur premier match de la saison à
domicile dans cette nationale 2 lésigny
monteyne en dominer patronage laïque
granville handball sur le score de 31 23
un festival offensif qui permet aux
joueuses de denys choulet de remonter à
la 9e place du classement après deux
journées avec un bilan à l'équilibré
d'une victoire il défaite depuis le
début de la saison
merci michael toutes ces infos et bien
d'autres encore à retrouver dans
quelques instants
votre émission le 7-8 fort juste après
le journal